jetzt in diesen stunden beginnen
offenbar auch chaoten krawallmacher
ihren angriff auf dem g7-gipfel hier in
deutschland das sind breaking news ihr
einkommen brandanschlag auf eine ganze
reihe polizei einsatzwagen ja das ist
eine ganze spur der zerstörung dort in
münchen das ist der ort von dem aus die
g7 polizisten staaten also wo sie
sozusagen ihr basislager haben dort in
münchen in einigen tagen wird dort der
g7 gipfel also starten am wochenende in
der mauer und jetzt war das der erste
anschlag die erste attacke dort auf die
polizei unsere reporter sind dort karl
kein reporter in münchen ich grüße dich
herzlich ka zeigt uns einmal diese spur
der zerstörung dort in münchen
ja man kann es sehen wir stehen hier in
der hochstraße im stadtteil haidhausen
ich gehe einfach mal aus dem bild heraus
man kann es sehen es handelt sich um
mannschaftswagen der bundespolizei man
kann diese spur der verwüstung sehen das
lenkrad ist total zerstört auch innen
drin die ganzen sitze nichts mehr wieder
zu erkennen
davor liegen die helme der polizisten
schienbeinschoner also die ganze
schutzausstattung auch dieser truppe
hier der bundespolizei die hier in einem
hotel genächtigt haben ja die ist hier
total zerstört die ersten fahrzeuge
werden auch schon abgeschleppt von der
bundespolizei hinten für die anderen
kommt dann kommen auch noch andere wagen
ja das ist sie gegenüber einem
hotelkomplex da sind die kräfte der
bundespolizei untergebracht einige kamen
sogar hier auch vorhin noch in
badelatschen raus die das in der nacht
auch dann erst mal nicht mitbekommen
haben oder geschlafen haben die kamen
dann hier auch aus haben auch erst mal
ein paar ihre handys gezückt und haben
das auch dann dokumentiert man kann
jetzt sagen also nach bild informationen
ist der stand der dass die ursache
sollen grillanzünder gewesen sein die
auf den vorderreifen der autos platziert
worden sind das ist eine ganz einfache
art wie man solche autos schnell zum
brennen bekommen kann und die täter
scheinen genau gewusst zu haben was sie
hier machen denn in diesem hotel komplex
informiert
da sind viele kameras auch die hier auch
diesen bereich aufzeichnet oder
zumindest auf diesem bereich und auf der
anderen seite der autos da gibt es viele
für fluchtwege die ihr unter führen da
kann man dann in der schutz der
dunkelheit gegen 3 uhr schnell
verschwinden so dass man hier auch nicht
aufgezeichnet wird die spur wird
vermutlich ins in linksextremistischen
lager führen die ja für solche anschläge
auch in der vergangenheit schon bekannt
waren ja bis zu zehn meter hoch dort in
der nacht die flammen ist kann es uns
auch berichten und wir wollen uns einmal
anhören was augenzeugen gesagt haben die
geweckt worden sind mitten in der nacht
durch eine explosion und durch flammen
heute nacht um kurz nach 32 minuten hat
drei bin ich aus dem bett gefallen weil
dieses auto da explodiert ist und den
luft geflogen ist und ich bin natürlich
sofort auf dem balkon raus sagen und
dann habe ich sofort die feuerwehr
angerufen die polizei wir haben aber
schon gewusst haben gesagt sie sind
schon unterwegs sei dann ging die
nächste explosion los ein stück weiter
vorne das war direkt gegenüber von
meinem balkon da vorne und das schlimme
war dass dieser baum der zum brennen
angefangen da vorne auch ja und wie
gesagt mein balkon es direkt gegenüber
und ich habe lauter fahnen draußen wenn
natürlich der winter ist bisschen blöd
gewesen wäre ja zum glück war kein
winter der hec gut ausgeschaut haben bei
uns alles zum brennen aller art
angefangen hätte können aber wenn ich
ganz ehrlich bin ich habe mit so etwas
gerechnet ja es ist nichts einfacher wie
hier da ist ein fluchtweg da ist ein
fluchtweg hier sind die über kameras wo
alles bewacht ist und so weiter und da
können die leute die wirklich kommen
hier alles machen ja
kelkheim unser reporter weiter bei uns
aus münchen zugeschaltet das passiert
also jetzt chaoten krawallmacher bevor
sein am wochenende erst losgeht mit dem
g7-gipfel wie ist die polizei
aufgestellt wie lautet überhaupt das
sicherheitskonzept
das sicherheitskonzept sieht so aus dass
hier mehr als 18.000 polizisten der
landes und bundespolizei im einsatz sind
sind 17 hubschrauber im einsatz
250 polizeihunde dazu die reiterstaffel
mit rund 50 beamten die dort in ellmau
im landkreis garmisch partenkirchen vor
ort sind ich kann mir allerdings nicht
vorstellen dass es zu solchen taten rund
um das schloss elmau woher kommen wir es
gibt um dieses schloss eine mehrere
sicherheitszonen eine 16 kilometer lang
führt dann einen zaun durch wald da
stehen alle 100 meter polizisten das ist
im hermetisch abgeriegelt da kommt
niemand durch und zum schluss selbst
kommt nicht mal mehr die landes oder die
bundespolizei durch denn da übernimmt
dann das bundeskriminalamt für die
bundesregierung die sicherheit also das
ist ein ort der ist weiträumig
abgesperrt
deswegen versuchen es denke ich mal
linksextreme wenn sie denn hier noch
weitere attacken angriffe plane das in
münchen zu machen in münchen ja man
sieht sich auf der straße man kann hier
einfach anschläge begehen das ist
relativ einfach in ellmau wird deutlich
schwieriger denn münchen hat eine ganz
andere infrastruktur und ganz andere
möglichkeiten wie als auf dem schloss in
ellmau jack a du hast vor wenigen
stunden mit bayerns innenminister
gesprochen kurz bevor diese attacke auf
die polizei dort in münchen passierte
und heißt sie ihm genau auch die frage
gestellt wie richten sie sich ein auf
die nächsten tage g7-gipfel dort in
elmar
falls jemand tatsächlich überlegen
sollte irgendwelche störaktionen krawall
oder gewalt zu verüben dem kann ich nur
dringend raten davon abstand zu nehmen
die polizei ist gut aufgestellt wir
schützen demonstrations- und
meinungsfreiheit aber wer gewalt an
aussieht will der wird von der polizei
zur rechenschaft gezogen und anstatt ab
stehen ja jetzt ist es bereits passiert
unser reporter karl keinen der steht
dort in münchen vor ausgebrannten
polizei einsatzwagen dort acht stück
sind zerstört das ist eine riesige summe
geld sie dort auch verbrannt wurde keine
wissens mit weiteren informationen auf
dem laufenden halten jetzt im vorfeld
zum g7-gipfel und wir begrüssen jetzt im
studio ganz herzlich rainer wendt chef
der deutschen polizeigewerkschaft
deutschlands oberster polizist sozusagen
natürlich mit ihnen darüber sprechen
welche sicherheitskonzept daher stellen
wir alle wollen auch länger man schon
haben die bilder noch vor augen g20 in
hamburg dort liefert man kann es nicht
anders sagen komplett aus dem ruder
jetzt stehen wir wenige tage vor g7 und
man hat den eindruck es gibt ja schon
die ersten anzeichen die ersten vorboten
der gewalt
ja gewalt gegen sachen weil gewalt gegen
personen ganz sicherlich auch versucht
werden wird aber in bayern nicht glücken
wird das muss man sagen in hamburg gibt
es von vornherein oder gab es von
vornherein andere verhältnisse das sind
die bilder von der harzer die in unser
aller köpfe sind vorhergesagt hat das
wird wie hafengeburtstag in hamburg und
dann saß aber so aussah es war der
jetzige bundeskanzler das mit dem
hafengeburtstag verglichen hat wo die
wir haben damals immer gewarnt wir haben
gesagt man muss diese leute aus der
stadt fernhalten aber hamburg hat
insofern andere verhältnisse als es eine
feste linksextremistische szene gibt in
hamburg die fest etabliert ist und von
der politischen linken auch gehegt und
gepflegt werden
nach münchen erwähnt ja die können nach
münchen fahren aber sie werden auf dem
weg dorthin schon kontrolliert und
sofern sich gewaltbereitschaft zeigen
auch wieder zurückgeführt
beziehungsweise in gewahrsam genommen
bayern die bayerische polizei hat ein
ganz anderes einsatzkonzept nämlich
deeskalation durch stärke sind viele
polizeikräfte vor ort die werden auch
gezeigt werden und die werden auch kein
zweifel daran lassen dass sie beherzt
zugreifen können wenn es zu gewaltsamen
aktion kommen aber müsste man ja nicht
ganz strenge sagen dann dürfte doch
jetzt so kurz vor diesem wichtigen
gipfel solche bilder gar nicht passieren
dann dürfte es doch jetzt gar nicht erst
geben ja die linksextremistische szene
bilden natürlich genau diese bilder
haben und es ist ziemlich leicht autos
anzuzünden das geht in sekundenschnelle
wir kennen das aus berlin wo jede nacht
jede nacht irgendwo autos brennen und
das gibt mit diesen anziehen dann sehr
schnell und man ist dann auch schnell
weg also man kann da nicht alle schützen
wir passen schon auf unsere autos auf
aber es sind viele tausend kolleginnen
und kollegen vor ort man kann nicht alle
autos rund um die uhr immer schön aber
wie ist das hier in diesem fall also wir
sehen noch mal die bilder daraus münchen
das ist sozusagen das basislager der g7
bundespolizisten jetzt sind die in der
nacht natürlich gegenüber im hotel
gewesen wachen morgens auf uns auto ist
nicht mehr da erstmal gewaltiger schaden
natürlich mehrere hunderttausend euro
vermutlich erwähnt und was passiert
eigentlich in so einem fall also holt
man einfach neue autos oder ist das
schon in so einer situation problem das
sind acht einsatzfahrzeugen ja das ist
der schaden ist wirklich sehr hoch der
steuerzahler wird es bezahlen müssen die
einsatzgeräte werden natürlich ersetzt
werden das ist auch möglich dass die
einsatzkräfte gehen trotzdem in den 1
das heißt das kann man auch kurzfristig
ersetzen also weitaus empfindlicher als
polizei ist logistisch hervorragend
aufgestellt sie ist auch gut
ausgestattet auch mit material hat sich
in der vergangenheit sehr viel getan das
personal ist aufgestockt worden aber
auch die schutzausstattung der
einsatzkräfte und die
bereitschaftspolizei die wir in
deutschland haben ist die beste gewählt
brandt attacke dort auf die polizei vor
diesem g7 gipfel in ellmau sie haben
gerade gesagt erwähnt das weckt
erinnerungen an g 20 in hamburg damals
und die geschichte ist damals war erster
bürgermeister olaf scholz in dieser
stadt hat vorher gesagt das haben wir im
griff das wird wie hafengeburtstag das
wird ein richtig schönes event oder das
gegenteil passierte dort in hamburg
wurden die straßenzüge wie sehen die
bilder von damals noch einmal
überstunden über tage in schutt und
asche gelegt werden dann die große
politik irgendwann in der
elbphilharmonie saß passierten draußen
schlimmste straßen ziehen nicht nur
autos brannten sondern ruhe gewalt
überstunden dort in den straßen was hat
man von damals gelernt event was diesmal
auf keinen fall nochmal passieren also
zunächst einmal haben wir andere
verhältnisse vor ort wir sind in bayern
und nicht in hamburg die
linksextremistische gefahr wird dort
nicht von niedlich oder verharmlost
sondern sehr ernst genommen und die
einsatzkräfte entsprechend aufgestellt
und es gibt in münchen diese szene halt
nicht es gibt dort keine besetzten
häuser und die gibt es in hamburg seit
vielen jahren von der stadt an der
schanze werden solche aktion nicht noch
vorbereitet sondern die
linksextremistische kräfte auch
mobilisiert unter das wird dort alles
trainiert alles das gibt es in bayern
nicht da gibt es ein schlüssiges
polizeikonzept die polizei wird solche
bilder in jedem fall nicht dulden